[Music]
as here and welcome back to behind the
screens this weekend
war for the Planet of the Apes it's a
one to watch and today I'm going to
recap everything leading up to war
[Music]
what I will finish it the Planet of the
Apes franchise has been around since
1968 as in almost 50 years it's amazing
and the reason that is that it's been
around this way is because they're very
intelligent films as well as being grand
entertainment they mean a lot to people
because they are such a perfect metaphor
for our times you know purpose but as
the years go by and the world turns and
events happen there's always a new story
to tell he's right the original movie
franchise pushed out five movies between
1968 and 1973 followed by two TV shows
in the 70s that weren't particularly
successful in 2001 after a mess of
behind-the-scenes effort to get it off
the ground
a reboot was released directed by Tim
Burton and starring Mark Wahlberg
unfortunately audiences didn't love it
so no sequel but finally in 2011 after
wanting to reboot to work so that we
finally get our first movie of this
current trilogy Rise of the Planet of
the Apes and it was really good Matt
Reeves who directed the next two movies
had this to say about why this franchise
works I really think that the advances
in the performance capture technology
enables the audience to identify with
Apes and I think that there's a really
uncanny power to that which is that you
go to the movies and you think you're
going to relate most to whoever the
human characters are but actually the
most human character is Caesar and Andy
Serkis is soul just vibrates to that
character before you see war this
weekend I'm going to run down the most
Serra bones recaps of the first two
Planet of the Apes just as a refresher
but you do have to see them you just do
so Caesar played by Andy Serkis is the
main character in every movie it's
almost easier for me to define the movie
by the guy who played the human so the
first one Rise of the Planet of the Apes
is one with James Franco here
Caesar is banished to a life of
captivity but eventually revolts and
finds freedom along with the other Apes
during the mid-credits scene we learned
there's a massive virus spreading around
the globe so the 2014 sequel
dawn of the Planet of the Apes aka the
one with Jason Clarke picks up ten years
later when the virus has dramatically
dwindled the human population meanwhile
the Apes to form their own situation and
they have their own method problem
during this movie the tension between
humans and apes is building through a
series of the trails and
miscommunications
and now in 2017 the war for the Planet
of the Apes you guessed it the war is
here years from now your children I'll
ask you what did you do in the greatest
war and you can tell them I fought to
protect this world this takes place only
two years after dawn and this time our
human is Woody Harrelson and he's the
antagonist hell-bent on finishing the
war and wiping out behave so that's
everything you need to know I hope you
enjoyed this mini refresher be sure to
LIKE subscribe and leave comments I want
you'd like to see in future episodes
until next time guys
[Applause]
[Music]